foreign
okay in the last lecture we derived from
f equals m a from Newton's Second Law
the equations of motion of the linear
harmonic oscillator which is just a
fancy name for a mass on a spring that
is oscillating back and forth and we
presented four different ways of solving
for the solution of that position X as a
function of time okay so we solve that
differential equation and today I'm
going to add a little bit of complexity
to this problem so we're going to not
just study the harmonic oscillator we're
going to add damping and I'm going to
show you again how to solve this
differential equation by guessing
exponential Solutions plugging them into
the equation and getting something
called the characteristic equation so
very very important this is going to be
kind of an important bridge to Future
Concepts so so pay attention
good
we're going to do here is instead of
just having a spring K that's helping us
move this Mass back and forth we're also
going to add a damper which is usually
drawn something like this
and this damping we're going to say has
some damping coefficient uh let's just
call it D or maybe I'll call it Delta
later
um and so in addition to uh to the
spring constant we also have a damping
so as the system is moving at a constant
velocity this damping uh is going to
want to slow down that that motion okay
so we're still working with f equals m a
and a is still going to be X double dot
the second derivative of my position is
the acceleration from physics so x dot
is V V Dot is a so X double dot is a and
so we can write down pretty simply
that our equation of motion is M our
mass times x double dot okay that is
literally just mass times acceleration
and that should equal force so that
equals all of the forces on on this Mass
the first force that we wrote down
before is this force due to the spring
constant this restorative Force so
that's minus
K times x so literally if I pull X away
from its rest position 0 to some
positive position X the spring constant
is giving me a negative force in the
kind of you know Negative X Direction so
the way I've drawn this positive X is
left so I pull this in the positive
direction my spring is pulling me back
in the negative Direction okay so that's
minus KX and it's proportional to how
hard I pull on this Mass
and then this damping term the way that
that works is similar to this
restorative spring Force I have a force
that is giving me an acceleration
at deceleration when I have a velocity
so if I have a positive velocity in the
positive X Direction this thing is going
to try to decelerate me minus D times
times x and again it's proportional to
my velocity the faster I'm going the
more this damper is going to decelerate
that motion
so pretty simple we just wrote down f
equals m a for uh for this problem
and I always like you to think about
what my assumptions were um so one
assumption I'm making here is that this
thing is only moving linearly so if I
actually built a spring and a damper
with a mask this thing would probably be
floppy and would not just be a
one-dimensional uh Mass unless I put it
on Rails or something like that so maybe
you can imagine this thing is on Rails
the other thing is this equation doesn't
take into account any non-linear effects
I think any kid who's played around with
a spring or a slinky has at some point
realized that if you pull the spring too
hard then it stops the force stops being
proportional to the displacement and so
sometimes it can increase even more or
sometimes you can actually break the
spring and then and then this is not
true so there are non-linear effects for
the spring constant if you pull this
thing hard enough okay
good but this is the equation we're
going to be working with for now and of
course we can move all of these terms
over to the left hand side and so we can
say that this equals
um you know m
X double dot
Plus
d x dot plus k x equals zero and I'm in
the habit of ordering my differential
equation in terms of the higher the
highest derivative to the lowest
derivative so my X double dots first
then my X dots next and then my no dots
after that so this is kind of my
convention for writing differential
equations you'll see at the end of this
lecture why I write it this way
um
good and then I think we're just going
to try to solve this differential
equation I'm trying to think if I want
to do one more thing
um
one more thing I want to do is you can
kind of divide through by the mass
and so if you divide through by the mass
then what we're going to do is we're
going to get this constant D over M and
this constant K Over M and I'm just
going to Define
um what do I want to Define I'm going to
Define
d over m equals I'm going to introduce
some variable I like
I like Zeta because it's fun to draw
because it is a fun letter I'm kind of a
nerd I have a you know personal
relationship with all of the Greek
letters so D Over N is going to be Zeta
and K Over m
we're going to call that
Omega squared so again we know that this
thing is oscillating at some frequency
and we're going to call that frequency
Omega and we're going to you know from
physics you can show that the square of
that frequency is K Over m
so K Over m is Omega squared
and if I introduce those constants
then I can write this differential
equation I divide by m and what I get
maybe I'll write this in pink I get X
double dot
plus d over M which is Zeta plus Zeta x
dot
plus K Over M which is Omega squared
X
equals zero so this is a nice uh
differential equation
that I'm going to solve now and so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
solve this differential equation using
the same technique I showed you in the
last video which is we're essentially
going to guess that the solution is e to
the Lambda T we're going to plug that in
to this equation and we're going to
solve for what Lambda has to equal and
we're going to get at this equation
called the characteristic equation after
I do that kind of you know on this this
light board then I'm going to fire up
Python and Matlab and plot the solutions
and show you that yes in fact this
solution does make sense good so we just
derived this equation now we're going to
solve it and the way that we solve this
thing
um
the the way that I always you know like
to think about this is that we know
basically the building blocks of linear
differential equations x dot equals
Lambda X are functions e to the Lambda T
so we are going to guess
we're going to guess
that X of t
equals e to the Lambda T this is served
us well in the past even for systems
that had Sines and cosines as the
solution like the undamped mass on a
spring e to the Lambda T was still a
good guess because Lambda could equal an
imaginary number you know I Omega and
that would give me cosines and Sines of
Omega T so again from Euler's formula
and the Taylor series you can show that
e to the I Omega T equals I'll just
write it out uh you know e to the
I Omega T equals cosine
Omega t plus I sine
Omega t
and so even from e to the Lambda T's I
can I can build up cosines and Sines and
exponential functions so anyway long way
to say we're going to guess that X of T
equals e to the Lambda T we're going to
compute its first derivative its second
derivative and we're going to plug it
into this equation and that's pretty
easy so x dot the first derivative is
just Lambda
e to the Lambda T the second derivative
X double dot of T equals Lambda squared
e to the Lambda t
okay so these are our building blocks
and at this point all we have to do is
essentially plug these in to this
equation and see what terms you know
have to equal what for this to be true
so we're literally going to
write down X double dot so that's Lambda
squared e to the Lambda t
plus C no not C sorry is that a Zeta
that's a Zeta plus Zeta remember I said
I have these close relationships with
all these Greek letters so Zeta times x
dot is Lambda e to the Lambda t
plus Omega squared
e to the Lambda t
equals zero okay all I did was I guessed
a solution I computed its derivatives
and I plugged it into this differential
equation which we know has to be true
because f equals m a is basically always
true okay and so now I have this
expression where every single term has
an e to the Lambda T and this is kind of
why we like e to the Lambda T's because
when we take their derivatives we get
constant times x times e to the Lambda T
so every single term here has an e to
the Lambda T I can pull that out and I
say this is Lambda squared plus
um
Zeta times Lambda
plus Omega squared
all of that times e to the Lambda T
equals zero because every single term
has an e to the Lambda T I can pop that
out
and this is a recurring theme in
differential equations is that use the
following property this relationship has
to be true for all of time x is a
function of time x is a function of T So
X of T and this f equals m a is true at
every single instant in time it's true
and so this expression has to be equal
to zero for all time here so if time is
zero one two any fraction of a second
this expression still has to be true and
the only way that can be possible
because e to the Lambda T is never equal
to zero except for T equals like you
know negative of infinity until Lambda T
equals negative Infinity this thing is
never zero so the only way this
expression can always be zero is if this
polynomial in Lambda equals zero so this
implies
that Lambda squared plus Zeta Lambda
plus Omega squared has to equal zero
this is the only way that this
differential equation can be satisfied
for this function X of t
and this is really really nice this is
actually exactly what we were looking
for is some equation to constrain what
is Lambda because I just guessed some
function X of T equals e to the Lambda T
and yes in fact I can take its
derivatives and I get things that might
work in this differential equation and
when I plug them in I find lo and behold
that there are in fact some lambdas that
will work and those are exactly the
lambdas that satisfy this equation this
is called the characteristic equation
characteristic
equation
and this is one of the most important
equations in all of linear differential
equations I'm going to write some
exclamation marks this is a big deal
because this characteristic equation is
what tells me which lambdas are valid
solutions for my differential equation
for what lambda's is this a valid
solution and it's exactly the lambdas
that satisfy this characteristic
equation
now I could do this if I had an equation
x triple dot X quadruple dot any system
of equations I had I could do the same
thing I could guess e to the Lambda T
take all of its derivatives plug them in
and I will get a characteristic equation
or a characteristic polynomial with
Lambda to the same order as my highest
derivative okay and I'm going to show
you that example in the next few
lectures so um so so we'll do that
plug it back into this equation and
we're done we have a solution so let's
do that
um
you know in my class I always ask my
students you know how many of you
remember how to solve this equation what
are the solutions for Lambda and most
everybody remembers the quadratic
formula but some people don't and it's
an important one so I'm just going to
remind you that the solutions of this
equation are um
Lambda equals Okay so
this Zeta is a coefficient and this
Omega squared is a coefficient they're
literally just numbers that come from M
K and D so if you have a real physical
system uh you know Zeta and Omega are
just numbers so this is a number this is
a number and Lambda equals
um
minus Zeta plus or minus the square root
of Zeta squared
minus 4 Omega squared minus four
Omega squared all of that divided by 2.
okay remember just from your kind of
high school algebra class this is the um
the quadratic formula that gives you the
solutions of this quadratic polynomial
in Lambda so we're solving for Lambda
this is a polynomial in Lambda quadratic
polynomial second order polynomial and
this is a solution from the quadratic
formula and there are two solutions
there's this you know for the plus and
the minus of this and some of these
lambdas are going to be real value
depending on some combinations of
damping and spraying and mass so
remember from physics over damped
systems don't oscillate they have so
much damping that they just kind of you
know you pull this thing and you let it
go and it just immediately goes to zero
without swinging or overshooting so some
of these would have real eigenvalues
some of these are going to have
imaginary eigenvalues if 4 Omega squared
is bigger than Zeta squared this is
going to be the square root of this is
going to be you know square root of a
negative number that's an imaginary
number and then this thing is going to
have oscillatory uh lambdas I'll get to
all of that in a minute I'm just you
know there are going to be different
behaviors of this depending on Zeta and
Omega okay those are those two numbers
and
um
so there are two solutions I'm just
going to call this Lambda comma 1 comma
two so the Lambda 1 solution let's say
is the Plus Solution the Lambda 2
solution is the minus solution
and so I can write down my final
solution of my differential equation as
X of t
equals and remember because of linear
superposition
each of this land these Lambda 1 and
Lambda 2s are both Solutions in my
system so uh e to the Lambda 1 T and e
to the Lambda 2T are both Solutions of
this differential equation I could
literally take this Lambda 1 and this
Lambda 2 and take e to those Lambda T's
plug them in and they're both Solutions
and so any linear combination of those
is also a solution that's a fundamental
property of linear differential
equations
so constant one plus constant two
and I'm just going to put this in maybe
a blue box
this is a solution
for all C1 and C2 okay and this is
actually kind of a good homework problem
for you is to you know take this
expression for for the Lambda plus and
the Lambda minus Lambda 1 and Lambda 2.
and take any linear combination of those
you could even just write down some
generic C1 and C2 just some constants
and now take this expression and plug it
into your differential equation take the
first derivative of x take the second
derivative of x you know written like
this plug it into your differential
equation and convince yourself that yes
in fact because each of these were
independently Solutions now when I add
them up it also still solves satisfies
this equation okay that's a really good
exercise to convince yourself that if I
have multiple solutions for a linear
differential equation then I can add any
combination of those Solutions e to the
Lambda one t I need to Lambda 2T and
that's still a solution good now how
would you find what C1 and C2 are
C1 and C2 would be uniquely determined
by my initial conditions so if I had
initial conditions for this problem then
there would only be a single C1 and C2
that would satisfy those initial
conditions so for example if I have
let's say you know x 0 equals x naught
and x dot at time 0 equals V naught then
I can say Okay X at time 0 is just
e to the 0 is 1 e to the zero is one so
X naught is just C1 plus C2
and similarly I could take the
derivative of this and I would get x dot
is you know C1 Lambda 1 e to the Lambda
1 t plus C2 Lambda 2 e to the Lambda 2 T
and if I plug in 0 I get x dot zero
equals C1 Lambda 1 plus C2 Lambda 2. and
so that equals V naught this is C1
Lambda 1 plus C2 Lambda 2. and I would
basically use this system of equations
to solve for C1 and C2 okay so I have
two equations with two unknowns C1 and
C2
I I Lambda 1 and Lambda 2 are numbers
that I have calculated here here x
naught and V naught are numbers that
were given to me as the initial
conditions of the problem and so I can
solve for C1 and C2 that uniquely
satisfy these initial conditions okay so
with initial conditions I can solve
exactly for what these C1 and C2 are
good uh what else do I want to show you
this is how you solve second order
differential equations in general so now
you can see that this kind of had
arbitrary coefficients you know by
changing the mass the damping and the
spring constant I get kind of all
possible second order linear systems
here and by dividing through by mass you
can see that really it's there's only
two parameters that matter and by
guessing a solution plugging it in you
get this very very important
characteristic equation this is kind of
the most important bit
and then because of linear superposition
this is going to have two solutions two
lambdas that work and so I'm going to
get two solutions to this equation and
any any linear combination of those two
solutions works and again you can solve
for those coefficients by the initial
data by the initial conditions X naught
and V naught for the problem
good okay so now I'm actually ready to
fire up some python in Matlab and just
show you you know we're going to
simulate this I'm just going to plot
some of the solutions and and that's
going to be that's going to be the
lecture maybe the last thing I'm going
to show you because I think this is
pretty important is
um I can take this equation here and
again in the last lecture I alluded to
the fact that we can suspend variables
we can introduce a new variable X and V
so x dot equals V and V Dot is of course
a my acceleration and my acceleration a
equals minus all this stuff so this
equals
minus Omega squared
x
minus Zeta x dot
the next dot is V sorry
um
so I'm just going to say minus Zeta V
and we can write this as a matrix system
of equations so when I do this in Matlab
I'm literally going to write this as a
matrix system of equations DDT
of X and V
equals and then there's going to be a
matrix times x and V
where now D DT of X is
here you can literally the way I think
about this is you know this Vector times
this Matrix does you know you kind of
knock it over inside and multiply so
it's zero times X Plus 1 times V so x
dot equals V correct and similarly the
second row V Dot equals minus Omega
squared times x minus Zeta times V so I
can equally well write this as
this linear system where this is now a
two by two a matrix and what I'm going
to show you in future lectures I think
in the next lecture and in the next
probably three or four lectures is that
the eigenvalue equation for this a
matrix is exactly the characteristic
equation for for this system so the
eigenvalues of a are exactly the lambdas
that satisfy this characteristic
equation very important property so eggs
of a let's call those lambdas
satisfy
the characteristic
equation that's a big deal really really
big deal because these are equivalent
systems like I can you know this
differential equation and this
differential equation are identical and
the eigenvalues of this are going to be
the characteristic equation of this
um okay good so I think I'm ready to
um do some Matlab it really boxed myself
into a nice little corner here this
feels cozy uh let's hope that this is
enough space for me and I am going to go
here
and try not to knock my computer over
good
um so let me just erase Euler's formula
it pains me to do it but I'm going to
erase Euler's formula you should
remember it by now if someone you know
wakes you up in the middle of the night
and you know at gunpoint
and asks you what is Euler's formula
you're going to say e to the i t equals
cosine t plus I sine T okay and if they
if you don't remember and they ask you
to prove it write down the Taylor series
for e and plug in IIT and show that you
get all of the terms you know that are
real form a cosine expansion and all of
the terms that have an imaginary
coefficient form the sine expansion okay
that's Euler's formula
I really can't get this uh to be where I
want it to be okay so what I'm going to
do is literally you know just code up
this
um in in Matlab and then also code it up
in Python so you can check the chapters
where you want if you want Matlab or
Python and we're just going to play
around with these Solutions
so um you know you can download this
code this is nothing kind of fancy
Happening Here
um
and what we're going to do is of course
I'm going to close all and clear all I
always do that in Matlab and then I'm
setting up my my natural frequency and
my damping ratio I'm just picking two
numbers for Omega and for
um
I think here I got lazy and instead of
calling it Zeta I'm just calling it D so
in my Matlab code D is Zeta so I hope
you can bear with me it's not this it's
literally
is that Zeta
no it's D yeah it's D sorry
um I'm I'm uh I'm being a little glimp
here it is actually the damping the
damping ratio let's let's just try it
out okay so there's just some numbers it
doesn't really matter I'm picking some
numbers for Omega and for Zeta or if you
like for Mass 10 and and and spring
constant and damping D and I'm going to
solve this in the same
way uh by using this a matrix so you'll
notice that this a matrix here is
exactly what I've written down here
where now this Zeta is minus two D times
w
um
minus two D times W I think you'll have
to convince yourself that this is the
same as Zeta
um I can't quite figure out why that's
true right off the top of my head but I
think you can uh you can convince
yourself that that's true
okay good
um
and what I'm actually going to do here
is I'm going to simulate this I'm going
to start by simulating this using kind
of the most naive way possible which I
think you're going to kind of like
actually so
um whenever I think about this I really
am uh kind of in a corner here so the
way I like to think about this is the
following
if I have DDT
of some X if I've got some D DT of x
equals some a times x
then what I can do is instead of
computing this exact derivative with the
limit as delta T goes to zero I can
approximate this using a finite delta T
and so I'll say okay well the Delta X is
approximately equal
to a x
delta T and this gives me an update rule
to step X forward by this little Delta X
every delta T every time step every time
little time forward I pick a small delta
T I can step my X forward by a Delta X
and so this basically gives me an
integration Rule and it says I can
update X every Delta X according to this
formula every delta T in time and so
that means I can set up a essentially a
difference equation x at time K plus 1
equals my last X plus this little Delta
X plus you know a
x k
delta T and so now uh this index K here
specifies what my time step is if I'm on
the first time step the second time step
the third time step and each time step
is K times delta T So time
K is just k
delta T and this is an update rule for
my differential equation
so I'm actually going to code this
differential equation update up and
that's what we're going to simulate to
begin with
so this is called the forward Euler
integration so again anything with
Euler's name is a pretty big deal this
is kind of the easiest simplest first
thing you could think of to integrate a
differential equation is this forward
Euler update I'll drive this again I'm
going to have like a whole three
lectures on you know when this is a good
idea when this is a bad idea deriving
this from scratch I'm just kind of
writing it down quick and dirty so we'll
get into this a lot more later and then
we're also going to use some built-in
techniques in Matlab called ode45 which
is a much more accurate way to integrate
okay so the first thing is we set up a
DT a little time step that's this delta
T here we also set up this big T which
is how long in time we want to integrate
so we're going to take as many steps K
as little DTS fit into Big T so it looks
like a thousand steps I'm going to take
a thousand steps and I need some initial
data X naught equals two semicolon zero
that literally means my initial
condition I'm defining here x is a
vector that contains my position Little
X and Little V and my velocity my
position Little X and my velocity Little
V and so my initial condition X naught
is really uh you know my initial
position and my initial velocity stacked
up into a vector okay so my initial
position is 2 and my initial velocity is
zero which means I pull this thing to a
displacement of two units and I Let It
Go with no velocity that's the initial
condition X naught
and to iterate this thing forward in
time I'm literally doing exactly what I
wrote down here in blue so you know 4K
as many little DTS fit into Big T that's
going to be about a thousand
uh we're saying well my time is K times
delta T that's what I wrote down here
and my x k plus one my my X at K plus 1
is equal to
okay identity times x that's just x k
plus delta T times a times x k this is
just I don't know why I wrote it this
way but this is just a times x k times
delta T okay and identity times x k is
just x k
uh okay and so we can plot that
and then similarly I'm going to use this
built-in ode45 Matlab integrator which
is a fourth order runga cut a scheme
again I'm going to have a whole lecture
on runga Cut integrators and why it's
good but for now you can just uh take
for granted that I'm using a really good
built-in integrator I'll show you how to
use this and what this means and you
know what the notation is of at T comma
x a times x this is creating a little
function on the Fly
for D DT of x equals a times x that's
what this notation is doing and I'm
going to plot both of those Solutions
let's hope it runs
it's busy it's running nice okay and I'm
going to set my GCA font size to 24
because I think that'll look nicer
okay so here I'll do that for both plots
in a minute
and I will show you what we are looking
at
okay so
um
what we have here
in these two plots
let me bring this up
the first plot here is literally just
plotting my position X of t as a
function of time
and I'm plotting these two curves my
forward Euler and my ode45 integration
and so you can see that they have the
same basic behavior that my position you
know it starts at two units so it starts
at Time Zero at two that's good and then
as you expect it's kind of oscillating
back and forth and eventually damping
out because this damping is going to
kill that oscillation and so this thing
is oscillating and dying at the same
time so if I computed Lambda I'm
guessing this would have a negative real
part plus or minus an imaginary part and
that means that I'm going to get this
damped exponential envelope with
oscillations uh in the middle and again
I'm going to derive all of that and show
you why that's true we're going to look
at what all of the combinations of what
can happen for all of these eigenvalues
we're going to look at that in the next
few lectures I'm just showing you that
this kind of matches our intuition that
this thing is going to oscillate and
then die out okay and there's a little
difference between these two curves
because forward Euler is not very
accurate this was a really cheesy
approximation and the od45 is actually
very accurate
and similarly in the bottom plot what
I'm plotting is I believe position
versus velocity X versus x dot or X
versus V and again in that plane you can
see this is called the phase plane or a
phase portrait you can see that this
system is spiraling towards a fixed
point with position zero and velocity
zero eventually it's going to come to
rest at this point here and in Phase
space this is what the Dynamics look
like
I think it's also fun to change
um by delta T let's see what happens if
I make delta T A lot smaller okay so if
I make it a lot smaller I'm assuming my
forward Euler and my runga cutter are
going to get closer together because
this is going to get more accurate I
hope let's see
oops okay
it's going to take a little bit of time
and now you can see these two curves are
almost perfectly on top of each other
there's almost no difference if I zoomed
in you could see it so decreasing the
delta T makes this a more accurate
scheme presumably increasing delta T is
going to make it way less accurate in
fact at some point it might even become
unstable
it became unstable you can see that it
my integration actually became unstable
because it was so bad this big delta T
had so much error it went unstable
so I need at least uh 0.01 for something
to look reasonable
uh using the standard techniques and we
can plot it in Matlab or python I
probably am not going to walk through
all of this python code it is like
almost identical and this is written
written by Alan captain ogloo and it's
it's basically the same exact ingredient
so you set up Omega and D you build this
a matrix you can integrate with forward
Euler you can integrate with the
built-in runga cut a scheme uh using
um this kind of solve ivp initial value
problem and it's kind of the same thing
maybe one thing I will show you is what
happens if I change the damping ratio so
if I change the damping ratio it changes
these eigenvalues these lambdas and in
fact so if I make this thing like
let's say instead of 0.25 and make it
2.5 so I make it 10 times bigger damping
what does that do
okay
so now my system is what's called
critically damped and you can see that
it has no oscillation it goes to rest it
basically goes from from my displacement
immediately to rest and it doesn't
overshoot or oscillate because it's
critically damped we'll talk about what
that means in a little bit based on
these eigenvalues but by changing this
damping ratio you can make it more or
less damped if I make it almost not
damped at all so I get rid of almost all
of the damping I'm assuming this thing's
going to oscillate a lot more and it's
not going to converge as fast that would
make sense to me it's taking a really
long time to run now
um maybe I'm freezing up my computer
let's see if it actually runs it
shouldn't be taking this long
I'm asking a lot of my computer today
there you go
and you can see at least the blue curve
is the accurate one this is the the
rangakata scheme the blue one is
eventually decaying but very very slowly
okay and it looks like my forward Euler
scheme my kind of crappy integrator here
is not doing a very good job okay that's
all I want to show you um so next time
we're going to do some more examples of
second order systems we're going to you
know derive another system like this go
through the same math solve for the
initial you know with the initial data
for the constants just to get your
intuition and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to move on to higher order
equations with triple dots and quadruple
dots and we're going to look at how when
you write them as systems of equations
the eigenvalues and the characteristic
equation mean the same thing so that's
all coming up stay tuned
foreign